[Music]  good photography is like a window  it's an opportunity to approach someone  else's life  and be moved by it  how is that this humble man transformed  not only south africa but the world  how could anyone endure so many years  in a tiny little cell and think about  reconciliation  that's extraordinary mandela comes from  this beautiful place  full of green hills and open spaces  where people are gentle and kind  understanding that helped me realize who  he was  [Music]  the places that mark mandela's life  have become pilgrimage sites where  people remember  the man who brought them freedom  [Music]  as you go around south africa you could  see his legacy  right there in front of you it doesn't  matter where you go  there's always a warm welcoming smile  it has been a fascinating experience for  me  and a great way to explore south africa  i just got a tantalizing glimpse  of this great country that's why i know  i will come back